hey so Jesse and I'm here again at the
Wolfram tech conference 2017 so if y'all
haven't tuned in I'm just kind of
interviewing developers and other
interesting people who are using our
technology in really cool ways and this
session I'm here with Ian and he's gonna
tell us a little bit about what he does
here at Wolfram and what he's doing here
at the tech conference specifically yeah
yeah so I been here at Wolfram for a
while as a developer writing code and
developing device drivers as well as
other operating system functionality to
interface with external systems like
other programming languages you know
complicated devices and stuff like that
and I'm giving a couple talks here on
systems like that
and we have the connected devices booth
set up yeah so right here we have an
Arduino that's hooked up to a shield and
a deferred neopixel shield where
Mathematica is controlling all of the
LEDs on this so you know the code here
you can control either you know
individual LEDs or all of them at once
and so we have it set up to kind of show
how you can use Mathematica to program
some of these kind of embedded devices
and build cool applications so since you
know anyone is tuning in can you kind of
explain what an Arduino is sure sure
yeah so an Arduino is kind of a lot like
you know a simple watch right it's like
one one exact thing and that's all it
does and so here when use it with
Mathematica it runs one specific program
that you know communicates with
Mathematica and in this case with a
little shield thing and so it's it's
really common and used in like robotics
projects or other kind of like do it to
yourself
electronics and yeah it's so but with
respect to the Raspberry Pi the
Raspberry Pi is like a full computer it
runs Linux
you know I can do web browsing you know
we're processing it even runs
Mathematica whereas the Arduino just
runs like one specific thing you program
it with one sketch they call it so you
can kind of like the Arduino kind of
takes in information and does one
specific task whereas the Raspberry Pi
can yeah yeah there's still a lot that
you can do with with the Arduino but
it's not running what we call an
operating system so it does one task it
is like one very simple processor and it
doesn't do anything else whereas your
computer you know in the background it
might be updating or it might be you
know downloading videos or you know what
it can do lots of different things
simultaneously whereas the Arduino just
does one one thing and and sometimes
those things have like important timing
requirements like so this you know this
thing there's a timing requirement of
like setting all the LEDs appropriately
and that kind of thing so you can't do
that directly from the computer and you
have to hook it up to an Arduino so a
lot of times you use Mathematica for
that where you hook up your kind of raw
hardware to the to the Arduino and then
control the Arduino through it so you
can hook up this kind of more raw
hardware to Mathematica using our Camino
is like a middle middle thing so is this
what your talk is about or one of your
talks yeah yeah so so actually my talk
isn't actually about this stuff the talk
that I'm giving tomorrow is on using
Python with with Wolfram language in the
new release of the Wolfram language we
added a functionality called external
evaluates where you can run Python code
and get back results and stuff like that
yeah it's it's really useful talking to
people here and getting you know like
they're like hey I do this kind of
application and Python and you know how
do i integrate that into the rest of my
Wolfram stuff and you know it's really
useful for people who have like really
complicated workflows where they have a
lot of a lot of different pieces to kind
of fit together and they can use
Mathematica to do all that yeah I think
before the only like external like
other language functionality was like an
event code
yeah so so embed code was was one of the
things you know I mean there is like
other languages like like Java we have J
link and dotnet and stuff like that but
with external evaluate of what we're
going for is a super easy to use and
kind of like you know just I mean
there's a lot of setup that you have to
do for Java and J link and other things
whereas with the external evaluate it's
really you know you just get to your
Python code and just copy and paste it
in and you're just ready to go yeah and
so what are some of the other since
we're not over there right here some of
the other demos going on yeah yeah yeah
we have a Rumbo hooked up to a Raspberry
Pi where the Raspberry Pi is controlling
the roomba and kind of driving it around
using Mathematica we have another demo
with Bernier sensors we're news a
company that makes these sensors for
like labs and educational purposes and
we have a demo of the sensors hooked up
to Mathematica and you can read them
right into Mathematica leave a couple
raspberry PI's set up with well one of
them actually is showing a demo of
former astronaut who decided to build a
thing for his plane to calculate loss of
control he did that in Mathematica and
built this little application that uses
machine learning and other things to
figure out when a plane is about to kind
of lose control and so we have a that
kind of setup over there so you can
check that out but ya know there's
there's a lot of cool stuff over there
I'm probably forgetting some stuff well
I think we have someone over there who's
also a hey you want to talk about it
okay it's okay
yeah no I think I think those were the
yeah I guess what are I what are some
like common use cases for common like
applications that you've seen with
Arduino and Raspberry Pi with sure yeah
so definitely one one big one is just
being able to gather sensor data and do
you know data science on that so for
example you know you have some kind of
like what I mean a very common one is
whether if people wanted like analyze
you know what is the weather like for
the past seven days and so you get you
know a weather station or you know
barometer or whatever kind of sensors
and hook them up to the Arduino and then
you can read that data into into
Mathematica with that you read that
sensor data into Mathematica so that's
definitely another one a really big one
is robotics you know people want to
build robots and be able to control the
robots from Mathematica and so building
these device drivers on top of the
Arduino device drivers is useful that's
that's kind of what we did here is kind
of took the base Arduino driver that
Mathematica has installed and extended
it a little bit to work with the
neopixel shield to control it but but
yeah so the robotics is another big one
so the first Arduino stuff was actually
my project as an intern and came in 10.1
that was the first kind of iteration of
it and there yes it was actually a while
ago yeah but yeah it came in and there
have been some you know gradual
improvements over the releases but that
was the core releases 10.1 so what are
you hoping to add yeah so there's a lot
of stuff I'm working on for 11.3
recently you know it really extending
out our connection to Python and these
other programming languages this is
really important for us going into 11.3
primarily because you know being here
getting to talk to users after 11.2 is
released there's a lot of you know it's
really useful to people but there's you
know specific things that they want to
do with it and you know ways that they
want to extend it for their own stuff
you know one big thing
adding like support for numpy this is a
big Python scientific computing package
and so adding support for that as well
as some other some other packages and
extensions to it is a big thing for 11.3
and some of them some of that I'll be
demoing in my thing tomorrow my talk
tomorrow ok well thanks for taking the
time thanks for having me you're having
two talks this conference so you're
quite busy so thanks again for taking
the time to talk about these things